What if writer's block isn't actually a
block, but rather a sign that you're on
the verge of a breakthrough? Most
writers, whenever they hit one of these
blocks, they try to discipline their way
through it with daily word counts,
timers, and putting your butt in the
chair. But, that doesn't work, and I
know because I tried it all during a
year-long block that nearly made me quit
writing. What finally got me through it
was not more discipline. It was the
opposite. So, in this video, I'm going
to show you what I think writer's block
actually is, why discipline makes it
worse, and the daily practice that
helped me break through it. And to do
that, I'm going to tell you a quick
story about how I broke through my
biggest period of writer's block. So,
this was during the COVID-19 pandemic,
and I was living alone in the Korean
countryside. My university had us
teaching online, and I was using my
downtime to work on the great foreigner
novel. And on paper, these were ideal
con- ditions. I had a steady paycheck
and plenty of solitude, a stack of
books, and my typewriter. And I could
essentially do my job in my pajamas.
Hey, I can do this job in my pajamas,
too. Where was I? Oh, yeah. And so,
despite these conditions, I was
completely blocked up. And yes, I did
all the productivity stuff. I sat my
butt in my chair from 7:30 to 12:00, but
I just couldn't write. And so, to get
through this block, I really doubled
down on the route of discipline. I
thought the problem was me and my
habits. So, I was reading, you know, the
James Clear book and really trying to
figure out how to force myself to write
words even when I didn't feel like it.
But, what I found is that this approach
makes things worse. And if I'm honest,
what started happening was I was
building up resentment to the work
because I didn't want to be there. I
didn't want to continue on. Even though
I had set myself this grand project of
writing a great novel, I hated doing the
daily work. Until one day I had finally
had it. I packed up my typewriter, I put
it in the closet, and I said, like, I've
had it. This is enough. I don't want to
look at this anymore. And let me tell
you what happened next. All right. So,
like, if that was a Friday, then it was
only two nights later. So, like, Sunday
night, I'm lying in bed, and I just get
hit with this wave of creative
inspiration. I started getting all these
ideas about the next project that I want
to take on and that I'm genuinely
excited about. I'm thrilled about it.
And plus, these ideas feel like they're
coming out of nowhere. The idea was to
take my teaching online, and that
eventually became this YouTube channel.
But it was so out of the blue. I mean,
you have to think, I'm a guy who's
writing on a typewriter. At that phase
in my life, I was very anti-technology.
I had all these, um, like, apps and
strategies to lock myself out of social
media. I didn't have a lot of social
media. And come to think of it, at that
time, I don't even think I had an
account on YouTube. So, like, the idea
of building a personal brand and and
learning about video, are you kidding
me? Like, this was all so foreign to me.
But it was only when I packed up that
project and took it out of sight and
stopped forcing myself to tend to this
goal that a previous version of me, you
know, way long time ago, had set. You
know, the version of me who wanted to be
a novelist and to write a a great novel.
Like, only when I could finally take
that off my table, put it away, did I
get hit with this wave, all these ideas
that, at the time, seemed quite alien to
me, but now has sustained my creative
practice for 5 years hence. It's
something that was truly me. It just
didn't match who I thought I was. And I
have to say this wave of creative
inspiration was almost overwhelming.
Like at a certain point, it was like,
"Okay, enough. Like I want to think
about this tomorrow." I I couldn't turn
it off. There was just so much energy in
this train of thought or the the source
of this thought that I didn't really
know how to harness it. And this has
only happened to me one other time. And
this was actually more recently. So,
about 3 months ago, I did a 10-day
meditation retreat. And I've been doing
these for a number of years. So, I've
probably done, I don't know, 12 or 15 of
them by this point. But on this most
recent retreat, I had a similar
experience. And I think in this case, it
happened for a different reason. So, in
the tradition of meditation that I
practice, we uh whenever we do these
retreats, it's silence. So, of course,
there's no phone, but there's also no
speaking and no eye contact. So, even
though there are other people there,
you're not engaging with others at all.
You're completely self-contained.
Unless, of course, you need to talk to a
manager about the food or a teacher
about your practice, you're not engaging
with other students. And so, there I am
in the Korean countryside sitting in
essentially a broom closet. That's the
size of it. It's a meditation cell. But
somewhere around, I don't know, day five
or six of this 10-day meditation
retreat, I similarly started getting hit
with these waves and waves of creative
ideas. And in this case, it was about uh
things that I wanted to do with the
YouTube channel and the website,
writerscience.com. And the point here is
not about the ideas themselves, but
about the conditions that gave rise to
them. So, what do these two situations
have in common? And how can you set
those same conditions in your life so
that you can find your best creative
ideas? Well, to do that, I need to give
you a piece of psychoanalytic theory
that completely changed the way that I
understand creativity and the
unconscious mind. Because ultimately,
that's where your creativity comes from,
the unconscious. And so, the basic idea
in psychoanalysis is that we are not a
whole coherent self, like just one
self, but actually, well, Freud would
have said that we're more like two. And
so, there's the conscious mind and the
unconscious mind, which is like an
iceberg. You know, we only know the tip,
just the tip, but there's actually a
deeper layer called the unconscious.
But, there's another thinker named Lacan
who takes this a little bit farther. And
I think this gives us a really good
model of understanding how creativity
works and where it comes from. And so,
Lacan says that the self, you know,
human subjectivity is actually made up
of three different layers or registers.
And so, he calls them the real, the
symbolic,
and the imaginary. And the real goes to
the imaginary, the imaginary to the
symbolic, and the symbolic back to the
real. And in the middle, there is this
force called jouissance, which bubbles
up through the real. All right, so what
does any of that mean? All right, well,
the imaginary layer of yourself is who
you imagine yourself to be. It's the
self that you see when you look in the
mirror in your mind. It's the story that
you tell yourself about who you are and
who you're supposed to be. All right,
now the symbolic is your social self.
It's the set of masks and persona that
you put on that help you navigate the
world and satisfy the demands that other
people put on you. It's your job, your
relationship, and your reputation. But
the real, to put it simply, I'm going to
say that the real is who you really are
behind closed doors. It's what makes you
uniquely you and I mean, you could call
this your soul or your true self or
however you want to put it. It It's the
It's the thing that makes you you like
nobody else. But the thing is, look, we
have these layers on top of it. We have
an imaginary self, like an ego, like
this story that we tell ourselves about
who we are and it's a story that kind of
has this consistency,
right? If If If somebody asks you who
you are, then you tell a story about it
and it has a beginning, middle, and end
and a coherent whole. The real isn't
like that at all. It's incoherent. It
It's It can't be contained. It exceeds
all bounds and forms. So, you have the
imaginary, you know, that self that you
see when you look in the mirror, and
then you have all these masks that you
use to navigate the world, your job and
your relationships, and all of these are
piled on top of the real, holding it
down and kind of containing its excesses
so that you don't, you know, screw up
socially and so that you don't um lose
this sense of self that you've
cultivated, right? These things are
blocking you from the source of your
creativity. And I think that's what was
happening in this story, right? Whenever
I was packing up my typewriter, I was
not just, you know, like clearing room
off of my desk. In a sense, I was
killing the imaginary part of myself,
the one, you know, I've been carrying
this vision of myself around as a
novelist for years and years and I don't
even know where I got this, but I was at
a time in my life when that ego was no
longer in service. And I know that
because in living out that fantasy, I
was not happy. I was miserable. I I
didn't I didn't feel free. I didn't have
a real outlet to express who I am, and
it was driving me crazy. And it was only
when I packed it up that I was able to
unleash all this pent-up energy. It came
through, and then I built up a new image
of myself, one who's here teaching on
YouTube, and you know, interested in in
everything that comes with this. It's a
completely new genre, a completely new
medium, and it only came into the world
whenever I de- killed that part of
myself. The same goes for the symbolic,
the the social persona. You know, it was
only when I was on this meditation
retreat and separated from all my
relationships that I was able to access
this new wave of creativity. So, of
course, these things are necessary.
Like, you're not going to just dispense
with them, but sometimes they can kind
of calcify if we don't if we don't allow
the energy from the real to come up and
invigorate these conceptions of self and
these symbolic relationships that we
have, then we can become stuck. And I
think that is what um writer's block is.
It's when, you know, this uh the energy
from jouissance is not able to come up
and inform the kind of persona and the
fantasies that you use to shape yourself
in the world. And so, in both cases, the
thing that unleashed this creativity was
not a new discipline routine. It was the
ability, in one way or another, to get
out of the way, to loosen my grip on
these constructs, and allow them to be
rejuvenated
through this energy that's already
pent-up inside of me. But I've got to
say, al- although this might seem pretty
inspirational and easy to do at a
theoretical level, it's not easy in
practice because we're actually very
attached to these things. Like, in my
case, I would not have easily dispensed
with the idea of myself being a
novelist, being a writer. And similarly,
the masks that we wear in public, to to
lose that we have that expression, at
least in Asia, to lose face, right? It's
very painful and embarrassing to lose
face. Because that means you are letting
down, disappointing the expectations
that others put on you. And so, letting
go of these can be quite painful, but
it's also painful to release the energy
through the real into these layers.
Because like the as I said, when I was
laying there in bed, I mean, you know,
these were exciting ideas that I was
getting flooded with, but it was almost
too much to bear. It it it's like it's
very overwhelming. In fact, that's what
these layers are for. They're
protective. These are the floodgates
that hold back these kind of tidal
waters. But the cost of that protection
is your creative work, which brings me
to the point that runs underneath this
entire video. You have to let yourself
die in order for your work to live. Real
creativity means letting go of control,
especially control over who you imagine
yourself to be and who others expect you
to be. But so, if discipline is not the
answer to your writer's block, then what
is? And how do you develop a
relationship to the real and to your
unconscious without forcing it? Well, if
you've been developing a writing
practice for any amount of time, then
you've probably heard of all kinds of
productivity routines from people like
Jerry Seinfeld who locks himself in a
room for whatever it is, 1 hour a day,
and has a rule where during that time he
He need to write, but he's not allowed
to do anything else. No phone, no books,
no music. You just sit there until
something comes. I mean, this story gets
passed around as advice, but has anybody
ever actually tried it? Well, I've tried
that, folks, and let me tell you, it
doesn't work. I think it's more myth
than actual practical advice. And, you
know, it probably works for a certain
kind of low-value writing. So, for
emails or reports, I guess it would work
to have a forcing function that makes
you do it. But, for creative work that's
uniquely yours, this does not work.
Because, look at what you're doing.
You're sitting in a room and you're
trying to force this to come up. And the
unconscious just does not work that way.
In fact, all this language around
discipline, when you think about it
through this frame of the unconscious,
you realize that it's just a substitute
for forcing the unconscious. And you
just cannot do that. It doesn't work.
It's your unconscious calling the shots
around here, not you. So, the best way
to understand this, I think, is with the
metaphor of the elephant. Oh god, I'm
going to draw an elephant here. Here we
go. There's an elephant. Big ears. Big
ears. Little
tusk. There we go. Big legs. Not bad,
actually, if I do say so myself. All
right, so you've got an elephant and
then you've got a rider
on top. Here we go. Holding the reins.
And he's probably got some kind of a
turban on his head if he's riding an
elephant.
And a mustache. Right. So, the elephant
and the rider. This is you. The rider is
sitting on top of the elephant holding
the reins. And they think they're in
control. And the elephant might have
good humor. It might take some
suggestions if you guide it this way and
that. But, if the elephant decides that
it wants to go in a certain direction,
what are you going to do? And I think
this comes up a lot whenever we pick
these long-term projects. You know, you
decide five years ago that you're going
to write some fantasy novel or some
collection of essays,
and suddenly you feel blocked. Well, I
think that's because you're up here and
you're trying to push the elephant in
one way, but the elephant is done with
that. That's what every blocked writer
is doing. They picked some destination
long ago, you know, it could be some
book project or some idea of self that
they had, and they're trying to force
the elephant to go in that direction.
But whenever you say you have writer's
block, I think it's because you've
picked a project that the elephant no
longer wants to comply with. So here you
are sitting on top of the elephant,
yanking at the reins, trying to control
it, and wondering why nothing's
happening. But what if the elephant
actually knew better than the writer?
What if the elephant had the writer's
best intentions in mind, and it could
see a little bit farther than the writer
could? Would you loosen your grip a
little bit, trust it, and let it take
you where it's trying to go? And what if
the place where it was trying to go was
better than the one that you had in
mind? Well, the elephant, the
unconscious, is working on your behalf
all the time, even when you sleep. And
so there's a name for this. Scientists
and mathematicians call it the night
shift because there have been so many
cases when a researcher will be working
on a problem, and then they'll go to
sleep, and the solution to that problem
comes to them in the riddle of a dream.
And so the famous example of this is the
French scientist Kekulé. He was working
on benzene. He needed to know the shape
of benzene, and he just couldn't figure
it out. So one day Kekulé goes to sleep,
and he has a dream of the mythical snake
eating its own tail, the ouroboros.
And he wakes up, and suddenly Kekulé
realizes, "Aha! It's a ring." And so,
Kekulé solved this very important
science problem not at his desk, but in
his sleep. But, this doesn't just work
for scientists and and researchers.
Anybody who's played an instrument knows
how this works. So, if you play guitar
or piano, then chime in in the comments
and let me know if this has ever
happened to you, where you are learning
a new song. Okay, so on day one, you
start off with that song, and you are at
0%. You know nothing of the song. And
so, you pick a section, and you
practice, and you practice, and you
practice, and after about, I don't know,
an hour or so, you get exhausted. You've
kind of hit your limit. You're not
making any more marginal progress, and
so you set it down, you go to sleep. And
so, let's say on that day one, you went
from 0% to 15% out of a 100. You know,
15% of the song you can now play.
Well, the following day, when you
practice that song again, do you start
at 15%?
No. You start at like 25%,
30%. All right. So, you make progress in
the song in your sleep. Now, I don't
mean that you're like learning notes
that you haven't studied before. I'm
talking about the dexterity to perform
the song. It becomes a lot easier to
play and a lot more natural to play. And
that's because the muscle memory gets
consolidated and streamlined in your
sleep. Again, in this situation, you're
working on a problem with your conscious
mind, and then you go to sleep, and your
subconscious gets busy at work to make
it easier for you to do it the next day.
That's the night shift. You were working
on a problem during the day with your
conscious mind, and then your conscious
mind handed it over to your subconscious
mind, which did its own procedures on
it. But why do you suppose it is that
the unconscious speaks to us in dreams
with these kind of mythological snake
shapes instead of just telling you the
answer in plain English? Well, simply
enough, it's because the unconscious is
older than language. Language came
around only about 10,000 years ago, but
the unconscious has been around for
millions of years, as long as Homo
sapiens have been around. And so the
unconscious is the operating system for
an animal. If an animal did not have an
unconscious, it would be a plant. The
unconscious existed long before we had
words to think with, and it still runs
underneath every thought that you have.
So, whenever you can't reach an idea
with this newest part of your brain, you
know, the neocortex, the language part
of your brain, the unconscious is still
there working in the background. It's
just that it speaks in a different
register. It speaks in images,
sensations, dreams, hunches, and itches.
And so, if you're feeling blocked, then
this is what your elephant has been
trying to tell you, and this is why it's
worth following. The unconscious is not
your adversary. It's not some chaotic
force that you have to manage, okay?
It's constantly working on your behalf,
solving problems that this new kid on
the block, you know, your neocortex,
this rational part of your brain,
couldn't solve itself. And so, it's
going to be composing the sentence that
you couldn't finish yesterday and
connecting the two ideas that you had
never thought to connect together. And
so, this I think is how I've learned to
trust the elephant, my unconscious. I've
learned through my experience that it
gives you what you need precisely when
you need it. And the times in my life
when I've just followed it, we can call
that intuition or grace or whatever it
might be,
it has led me somewhere better than I,
in my previous state, could have ever
imagined. You know, we use the best of
our knowledge to make our plans, but
sometimes those plans are lousy because
you don't know what you don't know. The
unconscious is the operating system for
the animal. It's looking out for you and
it's trying to tell you something,
something important. And so, if you're
blocked up on this project and it's just
not letting you through,
maybe just consider, okay? I'm all I
Look, I'm all for goals. I don't think
there's anything wrong with trying to be
more disciplined in your life, but the
problem is taking a discipline-only
approach to what is essentially a
creative endeavor.
If we want to be creative If you want to
be an artist, then you need to learn to
listen to your unconscious and follow it
wherever it's trying to lead you. You
cannot summon it, you can't give it a
deadline, and you can't bully it. You
are not going to David Goggins your way
through this book. But the good news is,
you don't have to. It's already on your
side. And so, if the unconscious is
working on your behalf, then the only
question left is, how do you give it the
room to deliver? I mean, let's say you
take this advice that you need to listen
to your unconscious. Well, all right,
how do I do that practically? Well, my
answer is free writing. And all right,
here's a way to think about it. So, if
we go back and you imagine yourself as
being made up of these three different
layers. You know what? This actually
looks kind of like a volcano. How about
that? So, let's turn it like that.
And then, let's say this is you, all
right, near this volcano. And then,
below you, inside, is this magma. And
that magma is pressurized and full of
energy, but it has no shape and no
language. This is the source of your
creativity. And so, free writing is the
act of pulling a little bit of that
magma to the surface every day. And so,
you sit down and you just write whatever
comes to mind. Okay, no filter, no plan,
and you probably heard something like
this before, but let me just clarify a
few things. When you do this free
writing, I think it's really important
to not have any pressure on yourself to
produce something meaningful. You're not
sitting down and doing free writing and
then trying to adapt that into a
newsletter. You're not free writing as
the first phase of your essay. I'm not
even talking about first drafts here.
What I'm talking about is dredging up
the real, or a pulling up this creative
kind of magma within you and just
getting it into language, into a shape.
A lot of which is going to be totally
trash, right? You're It's not even trash
because you're you're you can't apply
these qualitative judgments to it. It's
It's only qualitative against something
that you were trying to achieve. And so,
if you're using language like good, bad,
better, worse, then you've already
missed the point here. This the the
product of this free writing is not
meaningful. All right? If If there's a
goal to it, then the goal is just to
open up a vent, right? Because when
you're blocked, it's because these
things are blocking
this. And so, what we want is to open a
vent and let a little bit of this juice
out every day so that it can energize
and and rejuvenate these images and
symbols that we use to fashion our self
and and and our understanding and our
model of the world. All right? You're
just letting it breathe. That's it. All
right, and so when the magma hits the
page, which is like whenever what is
bubbling within you gets translated into
language, then it cools into a shape,
almost like you're dropping the magma
into a bucket. And so, when you drop
magma into a bucket, you don't decide
what the shape is. It's just going to
take whatever shape it is based on the
interaction of the original source
material and then and the new conditions
in the environment. That's it. Now, you,
as the excavator of this magma, can look
at that final shape, and of course,
you're not going to try to give this to
somebody else. It's not meaningful. It's
It's It's not useful. It's just magma.
But, it might solidify into a shape that
you can then refine into something that
another person might find useful or
beautiful. All right, when you do this
free writing, it's going to take
whatever form it's going to take, and
there's nothing that you can do about
that. You can't will it to be prettier,
you can't will it to be more useful, you
just drop it into the bucket, you drop
it into language, and you let it cool
down, and whatever you get is what you
get. But, that's fine, because free
writing is not meant to be meaningful.
It's not for anybody, and that includes
you. Okay, so, what comes up is going to
look like gobbledygook, and that's
perfectly fine. If you were a painter,
then this would be the equivalent of
just moving paint around on the canvas.
All right, this isn't an early sketch of
a painting that you're going to do, it's
not a um you know, a study. Sometimes
painters will do that, they'll they'll
do little sketches and different uh
experiments with the paint. That's not
what we're doing. We are playing with
paint at this stage. That's it. Magma
has no coherent structure. It's just
full of energy, and the whole point of
this practice is just to get that energy
out of the underground and put it into a
form that you can that is cool enough
for you to hold. But now, once the
magma's cooled, which might be moments
later or hours later or days later,
whatever it might be, then the
analytical mind can come online and you
can read what you wrote and you can
start to sort it out. And you're going
to find that a lot of it is dross and
that's fine. But you're going to also
find certain bits that have a bit of a
shine to it or sometimes they say it has
energy. Like there's something to it.
There's some I don't know what it is.
It's something you see, but you just
recognize something in it. Something
meaningful, something true, something
that you can work with. And as you work
with it, you're going to start to shape
it into something that you can share
with others. And that's going to be
something that's either useful, like a
tool, or something beautiful, like a
sculpture. All right, so this kind of
analysis is where your craft lives. And
that's when the manuscript, you know,
the newsletter or the essay or the
script, that's when it gets made. But
the sequence here is really important
because you can't sculpt magma. You've
got to let it cool down or you've got to
let these ideas
First of all, you've got to let it
percolate inside of you, right? You
can't force this to come up. And
whenever you do these free writing
sessions, you just get whatever you're
given. You know, the Greeks wrote about
this as like being being given gifts
from God. It's as though it's coming
through you, right? So you can't choose
what comes up. You've just got to allow
it to come up. And then you can review
it. And it's great if you if you do this
in a note-taking software because you
can use like a random note function to
kind of resurface old free writing
scraps and so you can really discover
things, you know, months or years later
that you didn't see the day that you
wrote it. And so even if you've never
actually done this writing practice, you
already know the difference that I'm
talking about here. And so think about
the difference between two different
kinds of conversation. All right. Now,
sometimes you have a conversation with
somebody and you're just in your head,
you know, you're a little
self-conscious, you're a little dry
mouth, your ideas aren't really coming
and they're pretty clunky when they do.
And if you do hit any kind of coherent
patch, what you're doing is actually
rehearsing something that you've said
before and the other person, whenever
this happens, usually gets a sense like
they're being talked at rather than
talked with. So that's a bad
conversation. But then sometimes you
just hit a topic that you really care
about and you stop monitoring what
you're saying. Like the ideas come
pouring out of you and even though
they're new ideas, they seem to cohere.
It's as though they're coming up from
like a a unified whole. Right? It's not
It's not an old idea that you've
rehearsed. It's not a familiar argument.
You know, as teachers we have these
kinds of teaching routines. You say
this, then you say that, then you insert
a joke here. That's not what we're
talking about here. But sometimes in a
conversation you just kind of hit your
stride and these ideas kind of start
pouring out of you one by one and they
have a kind of energy, if you know what
I mean. Like it's really exciting when
this happens. And now every time this
happens, you know, there are different
circumstances in which this kind of a
conversation might happen. But when it
does happen, it happens not because you
planned it to be this way, but because
you got out of the way. Right? You
weren't generating and judging. You were
just letting the magma rise and because
your unconscious is always working for
you in the background, it will give you
sometimes these ideas that are entirely
coherent, thought through, easy to
articulate,
you know, well-argued, substantiated by
evidence and experience, the whole
package. Well, that happens in
conversation and that's exactly what I'm
talking about when I talk about the
purpose of free writing. It's the
practice that makes that second mode
more reliable. Now, of course, you can
never force it, but by regularly
practicing free writing, you give it an
opportunity to happen. Now, of course,
most of what comes up is trash. Probably
90% of it, right? This is magma we're
talking about. But the 10% that isn't is
going to be better than anything you
could have planned. And that's how the
unconscious works. It knows who you are,
it knows what you're working on, and
it's always working for you in the
background. So, you've just got to get
out of the way and give it a chance to
step forward. The way to do this is to
write the raw material first and then
bring your intellect online to do the
shaping and refining. Meaning in these
free writing sessions is what you end up
with. It's not what you start with. All
you need to do is show up daily, open
the vent, let the magma cool, and then
trust that the version of you that's
trying to come through has something
worth saying. So, there you have it.
You're not stuck. There's just something
bigger in you that's trying to come up
and all you've got to do is get out of
its way. And to do that, you need to
watch this video next because it's going
to give you a practical writing system
that makes the pipeline from reading to
writing effortless. So, be sure to go
check it out.
>> Mhm.